so wie mais hat ja gesagt am samstag hat
sie ihren verlobten niklas castello
geheiratet in florenz und das wolle
natürlich ordentlich gefeiert und die
ganzen party dts die kennt bild chefin
giannina kirsch bei mir im studio guten
morgen giannina was kannst du uns ein
exklusives berichten was vielleicht
nicht schon jeder weiß ja also ich kann
auf jeden fall berichten das ist eine
grandiose party gewesen sein muss ich
habe natürlich auch mit einigen gästen
gesprochen und nach der großen trauung
wurde ja groß gefeiert es gab erst mal
ein dünner und das wurde dann mit einer
liveband begleitet und diese live band
hat es musik gespielt zum beispiel sweet
dreams von den eurythmics cws ein
riesengroßer es werden auch bei ihrem
geburtstag bei ihrem vierzigsten vor
zwei jahren war das motto eighties und
ja die band hat den gästen ordentlich
eingeheizt und ich hörte dass die ersten
schon auf den tischen standen da war der
hauptgang noch nicht mal abgeräumt
also die stimmung war wahnsinnig gut m
ist endete dann so gegen 4.45 uhr
morgens im pool also alle gäste sind in
irgendwann in den pool gesprungen
ich sag mal so wenn man ein bisschen was
getrunken hat dann ist ja ein bisschen
feuchtigkeit auch nicht das schlechteste
also es gegen auf jeden fall ordentlich
heiß her klingt auf jeden fall nach
einer gelungenen hochzeitsparty aber es
ging am sonntag auch noch weiter oder ja
am sonntagmorgen wurde dann natürlich
gemeinsam gefrühstückt es gab dann noch
mal eine ganz tolle torte da war man von
oben zwei kleine figuren drauf sylvie
und ihr mann sie in dem hochzeitskleid
von gallia darauf was sie am samstag
getragen hat und dann wurde gemeinsam
gefrühstückt und eine freundin von zeevi
ihre hair und make up artistin und sehr
gute freundin hatte geburtstag das heißt
es gab noch mal anlass zu feiern und
abends wurde dann noch mal der abend ja
so das wochenende haben sie revue
passieren lassen sind noch mal so mit 20
leuten noch mal schön essen gegangen und
wir müssen noch mal über den ring
sprechen ja funkel der glaube ich jedes
frauenherz wenn man diesen ring so sieht
der sieht ja sehr groß aus was macht der
ring denn so besonders also dieser regen
ist einfach ich würde sagen man könnte
sich dafür ein
zu kaufen es sei ihr gegönnt dieser
regen hat tatsächlich 19 radien diamonds
das bedeutet speziell geschliffene
diamanten die eingefasst sind in platin
von dem juwelier michael green schon ihr
verlobungsring ist von michael green das
heißt dass beides passt natürlich
perfekt zusammen 1919 diamanten
eingefasst in platin ungefähr ein wert
zwischen 40 und 50 tausend euro also ein
wahnsinns klunker sage ich mal so aber
es soll ja die nächsten 50 jahre halten
insofern etwas das vielleicht hat aber
ich kann sagen sein ring ist sehr dezent
sein ring ist gold und hat einen kleinen
grünen diamanten drin
ja genau aber wie ich immer sage sylvie
hält sich nicht zurück und der ring
passt passt auch einfach perfekt zu ihr
und wohin geht das jetzt für die beiden
in die flitterwochen
es geht nach capri die akp liegt ja
ungefähr liegt ja bei neapel und wir
kennen ja alle capri noch natürlich auch
weil heidi und tom dort geheiratet haben
da gibt es ja diese wunderschöne
romantische blaue grotte in der man in
der man schwimmen gehen kann genau und
da wird jetzt geflittert ich glaube es
ist ein wunderschöner perfekter ort für
die beiden das ist natürlich auch nicht
weit von florenz wo soll man auch
während corona jetzt irgendwie großartig
hinreisen und caprice klein aber fein
wunderschön und genau da wird jetzt ja
die liebe quasi noch mal zu zwei
zelebriert mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur weil weltschau die ich je das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren